خطط تاريخيه جديده للتسلح في اليابان
خطط تعيد رسم خارطه الدفاع والامن في
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ ملفات لا تغيب عن
زياره الاولى يقوم بها رئيس الوزراء
الياباني الى واشنطن منذ توليه منصبه في
عام 2021
وبين سطور تلك الزياره تعزيز التحالف
الياباني الامريكي ومناقشه السياسه
الدفاعيه اليابانيه الجديده
اليابان كشفت عن اكبر خطه انفاق عسكري لها
منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه بقيمه 320
مليار دولار لشراء صواريخ قادره على الدرب
الصين وتشتمل الخطط على زياده حصه الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي المخصصه للامن القومي الى
اثنين في المئه كما تم الاعلان عن ثلاث
وثائق ستجه للتوسع الجيش تتعلق الاولى
باستراتيجيه الامن القومي الجديده
وتعرض الوثيقه تقييم طوكيو للتهديدات
المصطفى ضدها وتحدد الادوات التي
ستستخدمها لمعالجتها الوثيقه الثانيه هي
عباره عن خطه الدفاع الوطني العشريه تحدد
التحسنات العسكريه المطلوبه لقوات الدفاع
الذاتيه للقيام بعملها فيما تحدد الوثيقه
الثالثه وهي خطه مشتريات تبلغ مدتها خمس
سنوات اولاويات تنفيذ خطه الدفاع
التوسع الاكثر طموحا وسرعه للقوه العسكريه
مرحله يدخل معها وبقوه اليابان سباق
التسلح العالمي في ظل الترسانه الصواريخ
المتنانيه في شمال شرق اسيا ومع تاكيد
واشنطن وتوكيو المتجدده ان بكين تمثل
التهديد الامنيه الاكبر في العالم
عصام عبد السلام العربيه